hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen lektion 43 hört
zu und spricht nach
vor drei tagen war montag
vor
seit tagen war montag
vorgestern war dienstag
gestern war mittwoch gestern war
mittwoch heute ist donnerstag
heute ist donnerstagmorgen ist
freitagmorgen ist freitag
übermorgen ist samstag
über
ist samstag in drei tagen ist sonntag in
drei tagen ist sonntag
vor zwei jahren bin ich nach england
gereist
vor einem
da habe ich deutsch gelernt
vor allem
letzten
habe ich nicht gearbeitet
ich nicht gearbeitet
haben mich meine eltern besucht
haben mich meine eltern besucht letzte
woche hatte ich geburtstag
letzte woche hatte ich geburtstag vor 3
war ich in basel
vor 3
vorgestern haben wir im restaurant
gegessen
gestern bin ich ins kino gegangen
tom wird heute bis 20 uhr arbeiten
am samstag wird tom ins kino gehen
morgen wird das wetter besser
mal
wird das wetter besser über morgen haben
wir eine prüfung
haben wir eine prüfung
ich werde am samstag zur party kommen
wann
hast du mit dem rauchen aufhören
wann wirst du mit dem rauchen aufhören
wir werden nicht mehr auf euch warten
werdet ihr bald heiraten
sie werden ein kind bekommen
morgen werde ich nicht zur arbeit gehen
nächste woche werden wir in die ferien
fliegen
nächste woche wie
wir in die ferien fliegen
in einer woche werden wir in die ferien
fliegen
in zwei wochen
werde ich die fahrprüfung machen
in zwei wochen werde ich die fahrprüfung
machen
nächsten monat werde ich 40 jahre alt
in einem monat werde ich 40 jahre alt
in einem
hat werde ich 40 jahre alt
in zwei monaten werde ich einen neuen
job suchen
in einem jahr werde ich mit dem rauchen
aufhören
nächstes jahr werde ich mit dem rauchen
nächstes jahr
wäre ich mit dem rauchen aufhören
in 20
keine autos mehr mit benzin fahren
werden keine autos mehr mit benzin
fahren
sie werden die autos ohne benzin fahren
die autos ohne benzin fahren
die technologie
schnell entwickeln
werden werden
ich werde ich werde
du wirst du wirst er sie es wird ehe sie
es wird
wir
ihr werdet ihr werdet sie werden
sie werden
ich bin gestern 18 jahre alt geworden
futur gleich wert und plus infiniti iv
futur gleich werden plus infiniti iv